dieser krater ist größer als paris und
er wurde erst jetzt entdeckt und der
einschlag hatte katastrophale folgen die
eiszeit verlängerte sich und zahlreiche
tierarten starben aus eine davon war der
mammuts eine weltweite platin schicht
brachte die forscher auf die spur
klicks und science fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasste nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
erst vor vier jahren wurde der
gigantische krater mit einem durchmesser
von 31 kilometern in nordwest grönland
entdeckt kein wunder denn er liegt unter
einer dicken eisschicht genau genommen
unter dem gletscher im vergangenen jahr
fanden fachleute heraus dass es sich bei
diesem riesigen krater um die spuren
eines meteoriteneinschlags handelt
beteiligt waren damals auch forschende
vom alfred-wegener-institut in
bremerhaven die das gebiet mit einem
leistungsstarken eis rabattiert hatten
doch nicht nur die radarsysteme
lieferten die entscheidenden hinweise
sondern auch die analysen von sedimenten
diese waren durch einen schmelzwasser
kanal aus dieser senke herausgespült
worden dazu der wissenschaftler nicolai
lassen wer an der studie beteiligt war
ein teil des aus dem kader gestrichen zu
haben das hat er eben jene die
informations merkmale hier auf einen
gewaltsamen aufprall in deuten dies ist
ein klassiker beweis dafür dass die
depression unter dem gletscher ein
veto-recht mit depression ist das
zusammendrücken das schlagartige
zusammendrücken des gesteins in diesen
krater gemeint mittlerweile steht fest
dass der sogenannte avatare zu den 25
größten 1 grad an der erde zählt die
entdeckung war zudem eine echte premiere
denn zuvor konnte solche an
einschlagskrater noch nie unter einem
eisschild aufgespürt werden
möglicherweise hat dieser
meteoriteneinschlag jedoch nicht nur für
diesen krater gesorgt sondern war zudem
auch dafür verantwortlich dass die etwa
100.000 jahre lange kalt zeit noch
einmal verlängert wurde
vor 13.000 jahren weil das klima
weltweit nämlich eher mild und alle
zeichen schien so als sei die kalte zeit
endlich vorbei doch plötzlich vor rund
12.800 jahren gab es wieder einen
kälteeinbruch und schlagartig kam das
eis zurück ein weiteres einziges
jahrtausend stand an in der fachsprache
würde diese periode als
do ass bezeichnet forschende rätseln
schon lange warum sich das thema
plötzlich wieder verändert hatte bisher
ging man von einem vulkanausbruch auf
island und oder dem vulkan lacher see in
der eifel in deutschland aus der ja
immer noch zu den aktiven vulkanen zählt
aber hin und wieder wurde auch schon
über einen meteoriteneinschlag als
ursache diskutiert ein forschungsteam
aus südafrika hat jetzt weitere indizien
für diese hypothese aufgespürt
allerdings nicht am kawata gletscher
sondern an einer grabungsstelle mit dem
namen wonder greater hier entdeckten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bei einer probebohrung im torfboden eine
auffälligkeit die rede ist von einer
platin spitze und zwar in der schicht
des bodens die einem alter von 12.800
jahren entspricht das edelmetall kommt
sehr häufig in außerirdische material
wie eben meteoriten vor
auf der erde ist es dagegen sehr selten
und der wander creator ist bei weitem
nicht der einzige ort an dem man erhöhte
platin konzentration in genau dieser
bodenschicht feststellen konnte
laut dem südafrikanischen forschungsteam
ist es die dreißigste fundstätte
weltweit vor allem auf der nordhalbkugel
wie etwa in grönland oder mexiko wurden
expertinnen und experten bislang fündig
doch auch die südhalbkugel war von dem
betroffen was auch immer damals
geschehen ist das zeigen die nun
aufgespürten ablagerungen am bonner
creator und zudem ähnliche ablagerungen
die vor kurzer zeit in chile aufgespürt
worden
das südafrikanische forschungsteam fand
außerdem pollen im wander creator borken
die zeigen dass die plötzliche abkühlung
damals tief greifend gewesen sein muss
und sich sogar auf die vegetation im
südlichen afrika ausgewirkt hatte
tiefere einschnitte gab es zu dieser
zeit aber vor allem in nordamerika hier
starb eine spezies nach der nächsten aus
beispielsweise mammuts und riesen
gürteltiere war also der klimawandel
ausgelöst durch einen gigantischen
meteoriteneinschlag der peter das
forschungsteam aus südafrika schließt
das keineswegs aus klar ist nur der
potenziell verdächtige metroid ist zu
dieser zeit nicht im wandertheater
eingeschlagen
der andere verdächtige ist eben der hier
weiter gletscher dieser
meteoriteneinschlag war nach ansicht der
fachleute auf jeden fall in der lage
auch der südlichen hemisphäre bleibende
folgen zu
doch erst wenn die entstehung dieses
körpers ausreichend paket ist kann mit
letzter sicherheit festgestellt werden
ob daraus tatsächlich die jüngere dryas
folgte objekt aus einer fremden welt
traf die erde anklicken anschauen und
den coolen nein man muss sagen
megacoolen kanal neugier zone kostenlos
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran